in that harvard health it says
a major survey of 127
545 american adults
that's what was referenced when they
said that married men are healthier than
men who were never married
men who have marital partners live
longer we went through that already but
that's a pretty that's a pretty big
decent sample size
what was interesting to me is that they
broke the study down in terms of your
heart
they talked a little bit about cancer as
we mentioned and then they talk about
the mental health what was interesting
about the heart was they cite japanese
scientists
and it says japanese scientists reported
that never married men were three times
more likely to die from cardiovascular
disease than married men and a report
from the farmingham offspring study also
suggests that marriage is truly
heartwarming
scientists evaluated 3682 adults over a
10-year period pretty long period of
time 10 years to track people even after
taking major cardiovascular risk factors
such as age body fat blood pressure
smoking diabetes and cholesterol into
account so this wasn't just a blanket
observation they took all of those into
account married men had a 46 lower rate
of death than unmarried men
maybe it's not so stressful
to be married comparatively
maybe there's a lot of reward in that
game a lot of enrichment and a lot of
calm and peace that comes from that
partnership when you actually take the
time to find a real partner and you
don't look to out strategize someone on
second one in a game that needs to die
just saying
and they dig into the cancer issue a
little bit they say
among people who received cancer therapy
so people who get a diagnosis and then
get the treatment marriage was linked to
improved survival again it's a support
system
it's a support think about that
everything you do in life you do better
when you have a support system right
a functioning support system think about
it like a group project right
when you were a kid
i always hated group projects because it
was like
sometimes you got a group that did
nothing that's not helpful then you wind
up doing your work everybody else's work
you're mad you're bitter right
oftentimes we didn't have the ability to
select that group the teacher just
assigned you but when you get a really
good group for a group project it feels
amazing
because you're all working together
everybody's doing their part everybody's
doing their share
they say teamwork what is it teamwork
makes the dream work is that how they
say it tyler is that it it works but the
team can't be lazy and then you're doing
you know it has to be a real this is
what i'm advocating for
i am advocating to find your way
back to partnership the system may be
broken but the answer is is not to break
it more
it's like everyone's looking at the
system and saying well the dating system
is broken so now you've got to out
strategize that person you gotta pull
back you gotta do this you gotta
how about the system is broken let's fix
it let's find people who wanna fix it
let's invest within them let's stop
playing the game all together with
people who wanna play the game those
people will learn they're gonna be alone
a long time if nobody's willing to play
the game with you eventually you decide
not to play the game either right nobody
wants to play the game all alone you
ever sit at a board game try to play
with yourself
sorry bb after a while you're like
let me go do something else
when i say starve the beast i mean
starve what's ugly
build up what's good you don't have to
settle for garbage
just because there's a lot of garbage
that exists right now
no
make a decision not to entangle with
garbage and to do better you will be one
of many people think about if everybody
made that decision
the garbage be sitting all alone playing
sorry not for too long before they got
bored then they'd have to man up woman
up and treat people better if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]